vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir 19 morts
depuis lundi dans les manifestations
contre la monusco mission de l'onu en
république démocratique du congo est
depuis lundi les manifestations
s'étendent à différentes villes dans le
sud kivu retour sur ces images avec nos
images exclusives de france 24
la guinée-bissau ultime étape de la
tournée africaine d'emmanuel damned
emmanuel macron il est le premier
président français à se rendre dans ce
pays lusophone qui vient de prendre la
présidence tournante de la cédéao
l'organisation sous régionale ouest
africaine on croit de nombreux défis
avec plusieurs coups d'état en quelques
mois
les législatives au sénégal j moins 3
après des semaines intenses et tendues
entre le pouvoir et l'opposition
le pays vit t-il un recul démocratique
en jeu et décryptage à suivre dans ce
journal
on ouvre ce journal par la situation
dans l'est de la république démocratique
du congo les manifestations contre la
mission des nations unies se multiplient
on déplore 19 morts depuis lundi et les
manifestations se poursuivent dans
différentes villes du sud kivu sophie la
motte avec les images exclusives des ops
de france 24
la route est quasi désertes il n'y a que
les militaires qui patrouillent elle
rejoint la ville de bukavu et uvira dans
l'est du congo un enjeu stratégique pour
les forces de l'ordre qui cherche à
stopper la multiplication des
manifestations anti casques bleus elles
ont commencé à goma ce lundi et sont
ensuite apparus à béni butembo et
ouvrira c'est ici que quatre jeunes sont
morts électrocutés par un câble
électrique
certains parlent de tirs de sommation
des casques bleus qui aurait coupé le
poteau entraînant la chute du câble et
causant sept accidents mortels
et nous n'avons aucune preuve que les
troupes de la monusco tiraient sur des
civils mais encore une fois nous menons
une enquête avec le gouvernement pour
déterminer exactement d'où venaient les
tirs
les manifestations sont interdites
depuis mercredi et les mouvements sont
restreints ce marché est normalement
noire de monde ce jeudi il est
complètement vide la monusco compte
environ 16 milles soldats et beaucoup de
congolais l'accusent de ne pas les
protéger dans un contexte grandissante
d'insécurité dans le pays
les combats au sol entre le patrimoine
comme moi c'est pour
la population est gaucher du jour joue
et pourtant des avoirs émissions des
logis pour ceux qui lisent et la
population mais la population est
massacré la population
on est d'ores et déjà comme des moutons
ah la la un sentiment partagé par des
politiques congolais
le 15 juillet dernier le président du
sénat a demandé à la monusco de plier
bagage un discours qui a justement
encourager ces manifestations
on reste en rdc où le pays a lancé ce
jeudi un appel d'offres pour l'octroi de
droits d'exploitation de 27 blocs
pétroliers trois blocs gazier le projet
suscite de vives critiques de la part
des ong environnementales car certains
de ces gisements se trouvent dans des
zones forestières qui jouent un rôle
vital dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
les précisions de clément monroe à
kinshasa
sur les vingt-sept blocs pétroliers mis
aux enchères 9 se trouve dans l'immense
région de la cuvette centrale qui abrite
des forêts tropicales et des tourbières
qui compte parmi les plus importants
puits de carbone dans le monde elle
séquestre environ 30 milliards de tonnes
de carbone ce qui équivaut à 80 2% des
émissions mondiales annuelles de dioxyde
de carbone liées à l'énergie selon des
scientifiques et des ong leur
dégradation pourrait avoir des
conséquences irréversibles sur
l'environnement développer des activités
industrielles d'exploitation pétrolière
dans ces zones là
va conduire inévitablement
à la d impact à la fois sur la
biodiversité que regorge ces zones là
mais aussi a
relâché dans l'atmosphère
les milliards et les milliards de tonnes
qui sont séquestrés une pétition lancée
au début du mois par des ong congolaises
et internationales comme greenpeace a
recueilli plus de cent mille signatures
mais pour le gouvernement congolais la
priorité est le développement économique
cent mille signatures contre 100
millions d'habitants
l'option que nous avons pris c'est celui
de pouvoir nous ne pesons gonese essaie
d'améliorer son quotidien à travers 100
l'économie
le gouvernement congolais évalue le
potentiel à 22 milliards de barils ce
qui pourrait rapporter 2 mille milliards
de dollars de revenus reste à savoir si
cela profitera effectivement à la
population congolaise la rdc se classe
régulièrement parmi les pays les plus
corrompus de la planète et malgré ses
importantes ressources minières les
trois quarts des congolais vivent avec
moins de un dollar 90 par jour
on reste dans l'énergie avec cet accord
historique le projet de gazoduc
transsaharien entre l'algérie le nigeria
et le niger a été signé ce jeudi à terme
le trans aérien devrait transporter des
milliards de cubes de gaz nigérian vers
l'algérie en passant par le niger avant
de poursuivre sa route vers l'europe
après le cameroun le bénin hier emmanuel
macron et en guinée-bissau dernière
étape de la tournée africaine du
président français
menu des discussions la sécurité dans le
sahel une des principales préoccupations
de la cedeao dont la guinée-bissau vient
de prendre la présidence on écoute les
deux chefs d'état
vais vous dire aussi il est déjà sur la
table
la création des forces anti putsch
en train de passer à trie
et ça ça va permettre que tout le monde
de comprendre que nous sommes en plein c
+ 21 c'est inadmissible inacceptable de
coup d'état on ne peut pas penser que
pour arriver
au sommet de l'état c'est un fast track
non comme bien dit auprès des macros ça
y est les processus procédure arrivé sur
d'état
donc il faut qu'on soit tous république
et c'est le peuple qui a les droits des
stationnements les dirigeants nous avons
aussi partager nos inquiétudes sur
l'amplification des violences contre les
populations civiles au sahel plus
largement maintenant dans toute la
source dans toute la sous région
et en particulier des exactions commises
par les éléments mercenaires déployés au
mali et dont les agissements sont
désormais documentée par les rapports
des nations unies wagner pour ne pas les
citer force est de constater que les
choix faits par la junte malienne
aujourd'hui et sa complice sa complicité
de fait avec la milice wagner sont
particulièrement inefficace pour lutter
contre le terrorisme ce n'est d'ailleurs
plus leur objectif et c'est ce qui a
présidé à notre choix de quitter le sol
malien
chez les voisins guinéens de conakry de
violents affrontements ont opposé ce
jeudi des forces de l'ordre à des jeunes
manifestants dans les rues de la
capitale l'opposition avait appelé à une
marche pacifique pour exiger des
militaires au pouvoir plus de
transparence dans la gestion de la
transition un rassemblement non autorisé
par les autorités explications avec
malik a quitté notre correspondant à
conakry
la tension a été vive toute la journée
dans plusieurs quartiers de la banlieue
de conakry notamment sur l'axé
hamdallaye bambeto et koloma des
batailles rangées ont eu lieu entre des
jeunes manifestants et les forces de
sécurité avaient caché des pierres donc
côté et tirs de gaz lacrymogènes de
l'autre les routes ont été barricadées
des pneus brûlés et les commerces
complètement fermée sur l'autoroute
fidel castro un calme précaire règne au
carrefour de la tannerie annoncé par le
fn décès comme point de départ de cette
manifestation a été complètement pris
d'assaut par un dispositif
impressionnant des forces de sécurité
pour le porte parole de la police la
situation est sous contrôle depuis 4h du
matin de gens nous sommes sur le terrain
pour aider ceux qui veulent circuler à
circuler et voilà empêcher toute
personne qui viendrait troubler l'ordre
toute personne est peut-être en train de
jeter de la
télé la situation est sous contrôle
thione voyez partout sur l'autoroute ça
circule très bien et en alberta et à
koloma marché nous sommes en train de
rétablir pour le chargé des stratégies
du mdc le mouvement qui a appelé à
manifester
il n'est pas question d'abandonner la
lutte aux qu'il estime être démocratique
tant que cette position ne s'inscrit pas
sur le chemin du retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel
le fidesz et va continuer à appeler le
peuple de guinée à descendre dans les
rues pour exiger de la junte le retour
rapide à l'ordre constitutionnel et
dénoncer l'instrumentalisation de la
justice contre les forces politiques et
sociales du pays on le prépare comme
catherine d'établir des civils pour
accepter l'instauration d'une dictature
militaire de notre pays à travers des
séries de manifestations le fn dessert
réclamons un cadre du dialogue avec les
militaires pour discuter de toutes les
questions liées à la transition et
surtout des sa durée qui a été porté à
36 mois par les militaires une durée
rejeté par les principaux partis
politiques du pays
on poursuit notre couverture des
législatives au sénégal qui auront lieu
ce dimanche les semaines précédant la
campagne ont été particulièrement
tendues entre le pouvoir et l'opposition
et de nombreuses voix se sont élevées
pour dénoncer un tour de vis du pouvoir
et un recul démocratique reportage de
sarah sakho sans brad pitt et mahdia
déthié fall fait partie des leaders de
la coalition d'opposition et oui askan
wi écarté des législatives aujourd'hui
il appuie la campagne de ses camarades
toujours dans la course arrêtée pour
avoir participé à une manifestation
interdite mi juin ils dénoncent une
répression des opposants
j'ai arrêté j'ai été enlevé vous avez vu
ce qu'ils avaient suivi le mandat de
dépôt et puis l'emprisonnement injuste
il ya deux valent plus ans sous les
opposants il a aujourd'hui des
arrestations nous avez vu des éléments
chaude opposant les élections
manifestations interdites affrontements
meurtriers en juin entre jeunes et
forces de l'ordre les vives tensions qui
ont précédé la campagne électorale
inquiète aussi la société civile la
culture démocratique faible culture
d'état est faible alors culture des
droits mais aussi faible parce que
toutes ces questions il faut les évaluer
tranquillement sereinement et
collectivement l'heure est désormais à
la détente la campagne se déroule sans
incident majeur huit listes nationales
sont en lice pour le gouvernement la
démocratie au sénégal se porte bien et
les accusations de l'opposition sont
infondées c'est de la propagande d'une
proposition dans la stratégie porte sur
la suspicion électorale mais sur le
saccage de psa ne l'accepteront jamais
et notre démocratie est en train de se
consolider et je pense qu'on peut sans
risque de se tromper
dépasser cette qualification
traditionnel démocratie modèle pour dire
que nous sommes une démocratie majeure
l'opposition dénonce aussi l'intention
prêtée au président macky sall de
briguer un troisième mandat en 2000 24
le chef de l'état a affirmé qu'il se
prononcerait sur la question après les
législatives
on va en afrique du sud où depuis deux
semaines les habitants vit sous les
coupures d'électricité entre quatre et
six heures quotidiennes les plus sévères
depuis 2019 et le pays perdrait 4
milliards de rands de tous les jours
reportage de caroline dumas stéphane car
c'est
dans ce petit parc commercial on gère
comme on peut les pannes d'électricité
ces entrepreneurs ont entre 2 heures et
6 heures de coupure tous les jours alors
chacun se réorganise
quand les lumières s'éteignent dois je
vais chercher mes pièces détachées et
dès qu'elle sera lemon je reviens
travailler
les générateurs sont très chers en ce
moment avec la hausse de l'essence et du
diesel si on utilise un générateur c'est
encore de l'argent moi
si vous promettez à votre client que le
travail sera fait en 5 jouer et que tout
à coup on a plus de courant on va mettre
bien plus que cinq jours j'ai perdu
vraiment beaucoup de clients comme ça
les causes de la crise sont complexes la
moitié des générateurs des 14 centrales
à charbon du pays ne fonctionnent plus
corrompus et ruiné la compagnie
nationale d'électricité n'a pas fait les
rénovations nécessaires sur du matériel
qui a plus de 40 ans le directeur
d'eskom ajoute dans une conférence de
presse digitale que les grèves de ces
salariés n'ont rien arrangé photo mc les
dû
malheureusement avec toutes ces grèves
sauvages cela ne nous a pas aidés alors
quand il battait déjà avec la maintenant
on travaille aussi dans des conditions
qui sont loin d'être idéales il nous
faudra plusieurs semaines pour nous
rétablir folie le câble
le président a ma pause à se veut
rassurant il dit qu'il fera appel au
secteur privé qu'il va accélérer la mise
en place des énergies renouvelables et
qu'il achètera de l'électricité aux pays
voisins mais les experts sont inquiet ce
journaliste avait prédit la crise dont
son livre en 2015
les centrales qu'ils ont commencé il y à
12 13 14 ans en 2007 ou 2008 ne sont
toutefois pas terminées et les unités
qui ont été terminés se sont avérées
déficiente et sérieusement problématique
l'économie sud africaine est limité
depuis dix ans par ses capacités
énergétiques
chacun sait qu'il faudra trouver
rapidement des alternatives pour éviter
que le pays ne fasse marche arrière
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
ceux qui nous ont suivis en particulier
ceux de dakar à bissao en passant par
conakry restez avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france 24
[Musique]